wolves and glittery vampires unite for a
look back at the final days on the set
of twilight every film has been like a
family reunion in the years since the
record-breaking blockbuster franchise
came to a close the cast have revealed a
ton about the very end of production
from breakdowns of the stars last days
and parting gifts to their most brutally
honest thoughts on the twilight movies
a lot of stuff in the toilet world that
doesn't make any sense robert pattinson
and kristen stewart's very last scene
was bella and edward's deer hunt in the
woods and since the rest of the cast had
already wrapped robb felt it was
ridiculous to bother getting emotional
with just the two of them
don't say goodbye to anyone kristin
probably wasn't in the mood either since
the very last thing she did on set was
step on a nail the duo's final day on
the twilight franchise was a lot more
anticlimactic than the twyhards were
probably hoping for
taylor lautner left the world of
twilight on a pretty lonely note this is
painful while his second to last day was
spent doing a scene with rob and kristen
his final day was spent filming all by
himself although he was sad to have
finished filming alone lautner still
managed to see the bright side of things
it was a little emotional but i mean the
good news is we will be able to promote
breaking dawn part 1 and 2 together for
the next year and a half
jackson rathbone and ashley greene were
lucky enough to have two last days their
last day with the director bill condon
and the rest of the first unit crew was
the wedding reception with everyone
there including nikki reed whose last
day it actually was that was your last
thing yeah as lovely as that send-off
would have been for them the moment
didn't really sink in for the duo since
they and kellen lutz still had one more
day of fight scenes to film with the
second unit unfortunately the last day
was a little less enjoyable even though
the last day was like 15 16 hours it was
raining and wet and then everybody was
just excited to get home the streak of
anticlimactic last days continues with
co-stars elizabeth reeser and peter
facianelli for their final day filming
on the twilight franchise the heads of
the cullen clan did a simple scene of
them walking up from the backyard of the
cullen house and unlike ashley green and
jackson rathbone the moment sunk in for
them immediately and we just hugged for
like five minutes
and then we went to dinner then we went
to dinner
actor anna kendrick found her experience
on twilight to be both very challenging
and weirdly bonding and she will not
miss it kendrick played a much smaller
role later on in the series which meant
a lot less time on the set for breaking
dawn not only did she not have to show
up until the final day of shooting with
the first unit but she also had to
promote breaking dawn part one i can
tell you this i'm not in breaking dawn
part two so i don't have to talk about
it
i'm just kidding taylor lautner had a
couple of things from twilight that he
was happy to say goodbye to including
taking his shirt off while it may have
been a treat for fans lautner did not
enjoy being the only one who was
shirtless on set especially in the cold
and wet conditions they always filmed in
but for lautner nothing was worse than
having to wear that dreaded wig there
was hatred between both of us it did not
like me i did not like it not fond
memories
after playing esme cullen for a whopping
five movies the only thing actor
elizabeth reeser wishes she had done was
take a memento to commemorate her time
on the twilight franchise i regret that
i didn't steal anything but i found that
stealing from sets is not good she was
not alone as fellow clan member nikki
reed was also too afraid to swipe
anything
i just was feeling so nervous that i
would be in trouble after rapping on the
twilight movies actor nikki reed
revealed some on-set tension between her
and co-stars kristen stewart and robert
pattinson likely stemming from her
alleged love triangle with robert and
kristen and her character's absence from
most of new moon reed felt that the
family dynamic on set had disappeared by
the end i don't feel particularly
sentimental i feel like we're all sort
of ready to graduate middle school and
move on to whatever the next chapter is
but we'll always be this
once his time on twilight was finished
kellen lutz was not afraid to get candid
about the franchise especially when it
came to the writing i didn't like the
script how scary would a glimmering
vampire really be it just doesn't make
sense he was also not a big fan of
shooting days with the entire ensemble
cast griping that he would often just
end up standing around all day with
nothing to do but when it came to his
own character lutz was surprisingly
sentimental there's a lot of emmett in
kellen and a lot of kellen and emmett
and i'm going to bring emmett with me
for the rest of my life
robert pattinson has never been one to
hide his true feelings especially when
it comes to the twilight movies he felt
weird representing a franchise that he
was not a particular fan of and when he
was asked if he would have gone to see
twilight if he wasn't in it his response
was pretty blunt i would just mindlessly
hate it despite his distaste for the
films he did admit he'll miss filming
them just a little yeah i think i will
miss it a bit one thing elizabeth reeser
won't miss is the colored contact lenses
the vampires in the cast were forced to
wear and peter faginelli elaborated on
why i remember elizabeth woke up one day
and her eyes were swollen shut i was
like i play a doctor but i can't help
you elizabeth actor maggie grace chimed
in as well adding that some of the
contacts were even hard to see through
it was funny some you could see through
and some you just couldn't so it was a
little strange to be you know in a scene
with someone that you couldn't see
co-stars kristen stewart robert
pattinson and michael sheen were not
fans of the painful contacts either so
glad to see you here after all the
lovable on-screen couple of ashley green
and jackson rathbone had an equally
lovable view with their time with their
cast members off-screen the two
described every film after the first as
a kind of family reunion and felt that
growing up together on these films
really bonded the core cast however
there were also a number of things they
definitely won't miss about twilight
including the dreary weather white
makeup long night shoots and those
annoying wigs the contacts the wigs the
wigs
for breaking dawn kellen lutz wanted to
add a little more muscle to his already
ripped frame but he may have gone a
little overboard i caught really big
seven months of working out that's
double the time we had for the other
movies i was just eating and working out
because i had a lot of down time so i
just would watch football in the gym
work out so after they wrapped let's
chilled on the workouts for a little
while i think we can all agree kellen
earned himself a break
after his extensive time on twilight
peter facinelli was determined to get
his own unique parting gift carlisle's
ring he had actually been caught trying
to swipe it from the set on the first
movie but with the series coming to an
end he saw another opportunity and
pounced on it when we did breaking dawn
part 2 it might have or it might not
have been left on my finger when i got
home
thanks to the staggered scheduling and
multiple shooting units the final
confrontation in breaking dawn part 2
was the first and last time the entire
cast was together that fact made things
a bit bittersweet for some of the actors
including peter faginelli the other day
when we shot that ending sequence we
knew that was the ending of the last two
movies and it got a little melancholy it
was sad on the bright side for
fatcinelli that specific sequence took
several weeks to film so the cast had
plenty of time to spend together however
robert pattinson wasn't so psyched about
the lengthy shoot being on a piece of
fake snow surrounded by green screen for
like a month it's driving me absolutely
insane
and then they just end it and it's like
well okay well that's that with the
addition of the young mackenzie foy for
the breaking dawn productions the crew
introduced a swear jar to try and keep a
lid on the profanity on set which cast
members do you think contributed the
most to the jar could you keep a lid on
your own salty language let us know in
the comments
you